notre histoire commence à l'école des
sorciers pas à poudlard non un chant
très nous des enfants de moldus découpe
des mélanges virtuellement des morceaux
d'animaux peu ragoûtant dans la potion
déjà une affinité perdre foi est un
foutoir
c'est souvent que tu découpes dernier en
morceaux bah non c'est un peu ce que tu
fais là parce que je fais mais en même
temps de sa muse et elle fait quoi ta
position à l'arrivée et ben en fait ça
se transforme en une sorcière ou un
superchampion de maths on peut dire ça
c'est l'atelier des potions est un jeu
pour ceux qui ne comprennent pas le
quart de la moitié du tiers des
problèmes de fractions et si villersexel
à la chance de le tester
c'est parce que le professeur rogue qui
l'a inventé est un ancien élève du cru
qui ne croient pas au mauvais sort
danton à 9 et enfin donc un alien je
pensais en neuvième
il n'y a pas de malédiction il n'y a pas
des gens qui sont pas du tout fait pour
les maths
non a priori non il ya vraiment les
études neurosciences le monde il n'y a
pas deux enfants prédisposé à être
mauvais en maths
donc les difficultés elles elles sont
didactique sociale
affective mais notre objectif c'est de
trouver du dispositif pour lever ces
obstacles à toutes les manières ludiques
sont intéressants pour l'enseignant
parce que les élèves y sont avec nous
ils sont super motivés ils en font plus
que 6 et des exercices traditionnels
convaincu que la formule est bonne le
syndicat intercommunal qui ne fait pas
dans la demi mesure a donc fait en sorte
de faire bouillir la marmite
le but c'est d'améliorer les conditions
de scolarisation dans tous les domaines
pour permettre à nos élèves de rejoindre
le collège dans les meilleures
conditions
mauvaise élève en maths
la france fait donc des efforts dommage
un sorcier quand il faut taire le nom
vient de faire disparaître la discipline
aux premières
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]